[Music]
let's go to louisa in denver colorado
luisa what's going on
so i
am calling because i lost my
sorry let me try to get through this no
you're good you're hey louis
take your time okay take your time okay
i lost my
16 year old son to suicide um 29 months
ago
and
i just can't seem to get past
the grief
the pain
the guilt um
and i just i don't i don't know what to
do i don't know how to move forward
um i feel like i take steps forward and
then just go right back to
day one yeah
i'm so sorry what was his name
police louise how old was he he was 16
you said 16. mm-hmm
tell me what happened
um
louis suffered from mental illness
depression anxiety ptsd
but you know we were doing all the
things
therapy
had
support at school
had support at home
and just
the morning of his death
um him and i got in a huge fight
um
and you know i can't even remember the
details of the argument um
he had spent some time with his dad that
morning and um
then we were leaving for a birthday
party and he didn't want to go
well you know wanted to do his own thing
and it just
snowballed quickly
very very quickly and
screaming and yelling and
i told him you know what we're gonna go
we're gonna do our own thing you say you
go do your thing your dad's coming for
you
you know do your thing and
we left and i have two younger
children who left with me
and we got home and
found him
golly
you saw something that no mother's ever
ever supposed to see or experience
i'm so so sorry
[Music]
and so walk me through what's been
life's been like the last
two and a half years now or two plus
years
um
it's very hard because i'm
i'm a school counselor oh jeez louise
you're supposed to know all the answers
luisa i should know all of that right
like i should have saved him
i should have been able to
keep him alive that's my job as a mom
that's my job as a mental health
professional
and so that's where a lot of the guilt
comes from
um is i should have known and
did better
and
i feel like i did it and
i try now to just
it's very hard working with other kids
in the same situation or similar
situations
um and it
constantly re-traumatizes me
my little ones are doing okay
but i feel like my job is to make sure
they're supported and that they're taken
care of they have the therapy they have
the support
um
i also have a 21 year old son and um
i feel like my job is to protect him now
so it's just it's hard i struggle every
day with making decisions
um
just knowing what to do not breaking
down in front of my children not
breaking down in front of students i
work with
yeah um
so
man there's so much and if i if i was
with you right now
with your permission of course i would
hug you for the next 10 minutes and not
say a word
um you've probably had plenty of
well-meaning yet
painful
recommendations and advice and little
pithy things given to you over the last
couple of years um
and you've probably looked at all the
blogs and all the
you know the
books and all the stuff right have you
got counseling on your own
um i did in the beginning and then i
stopped because
i had to take care of every video
man
so
i don't want to presume that to just
jump in here and start throwing stuff at
you so
um
how can i walk alongside with you in
this i've got a thousand things circling
through my head but i want to know what
you need right now
i guess my biggest thing is like
i know what i need to do right like i
know i need the therapy
i know i need to take care of myself
um
but i don't know how to do that i don't
know how to
stay on track with anything
i
don't know how to commit to anything
um
so how do i do that how do i
make a commitment to
start therapy again how do i
i don't know i don't even know where to
start or what to do or
um
the conversation we're about to have is
better had in person okay
and you're you're a mental health
professional i'm just a
pretend guy on the radio right on a
podcast but
this conversation's better had in person
but we're gonna have it over the phone
is that okay
yeah okay
um
a couple things i'm hearing that i want
to jump in the middle of
okay
and some of this you know what i'm about
to say i'm gonna say it anyway because
you gotta hear it okay and this is
probably the same stuff you've told
parents
in your career
probably better than i'm gonna tell you
but your son
passing is not your fault
and
you've beat up my friend louisa for two
and a half years now
and
you can't fully help your kids that are
still with you you can't fully honor
luis's memory you can't fully
um help the kids that you help at school
until you stop beating up yourself
till you forgive you set stuff down
and breathe
okay
until you believe
and don't just say it out loud but until
you believe that you're worth being
loved you're worth being okay
you're not this stuff's gonna stay this
close to the surface and you think all
this is about him right now but it's not
it's about you right now
how many times have you replayed that
morning
in the last two years
oh
daily yeah exactly
and your body has spent the last two and
a half years looking for every possible
possible moment this could happen again
and you haven't taken a full breath in
two years
is that true
yes yeah
and your identity as a mom was shattered
your identity as a counselor was
shattered your identity as a protector
and a provider was shattered
and all that's true
and so healing moving forward is
is
about building a new identity about
living into something new and
until you stop trying to regain what was
and start living into what is and what
will be
my friend you're it's gonna you're gonna
feel like you're treading water in a
really rough seas
and every third breath you're gonna be
breathing in water
do you believe this is your fault
be honest be honest
yes have you ever heard me lie to
anybody
no
okay i'm not starting today it's not
your fault
it's not your
fault your son was hurting for a long
long time
and i don't think that he wanted to die
i think he wanted to stop hurting
and one of the great demons of
the great great lies of a mind that is
struggling with
suicide is
they believe they're a burden to other
people and they look for every possible
shred of evidence to back that story up
it becomes a vacuum right
and
he turned a
saturday morning spat
that every mom and every son and every
parent and every kid and every brother
and every sister and every coworker have
into
a story that it wasn't
and it's not because he was trying to be
ugly or means because he was wasn't well
right
and like the mother who's driving down
the road
five five miles an hour below the speed
limit and the kid runs out in front of
the car
the car hit him but that wasn't her
fault
and this was the fight
the yelling the the permanent solution
to a short-term problem is not on on you
and if nothing else in this phone call i
want you to hear me tell you i love you
your kids love you
and this is not your fault
will you say those words out loud
this was not my paul
thank you
and you said it with a question mark at
the end of it but i'll let it go this
time okay
so
in my work in crisis work one of the
things i
ran up on that surprised me and you've
i've talked about on this show several
times
is i ran up against my own limitations
which i didn't know existed
when i got called to a few scenes that
involved young children and i had a baby
little girl and i left
and i found there was a limit
and so as we walk through what do you do
next what does healing look like for you
moving forward
how do you get the gumption to even take
care of yourself
i want you to keep in mind that for a
season
i had to not be in that environment with
that particular group of people so that
i could heal
and it may mean that for the next two
years three years five years one
semester whatever that looks like
that
working in mental health with
teenage kids
is gonna prohibit you from
healing that doesn't mean it's a forever
thing in fact i don't think it's for
everything in fact i think you become
one of the most powerful voices in the
country on this
but you got to heal first
you can't show your scar around you
can't you can't show your scars and talk
about your scars while they're still
bleeding
and so healing
in this in your walk starts with you
even thinking you're worth healing
because right now you don't
you think you're a mom that failed you
think you're a mental health
professional that failed and until you
think you're worth
breathing again and smiling again and
sleeping again and laughing again until
you believe that
your body's gonna keep going to war with
you
and so
i've heard it
multiple ways and i don't care which way
you find it
because right now you're still in
survival mode
i've had veterans tell me that
they got home and lost some of their
their partners on the battlefield
that every day of their life is in
memory of in service to those who didn't
come home great
i've heard people who lose a child say
i'm gonna stand up and live for me
because i deserve it great
i'm gonna live
for my i'm gonna make meaning of this
i'm not going to let my child have
passed in vain i'm going to make sure
that there's no more drunk drivers in
the road that no more young kids take
their life whatever whatever this looks
like that that my kid no other kid ever
gets cancer like my kid did
i don't care how you do it or why you do
it but you've got to have an arrow that
you are pointing towards
you got to have a marker somewhere and
it will change over time but you got to
have something that says this is the
light worth getting out of bed for
because right now your light that you're
getting out of bed for is a
is not true it's a bunch of shoulds
and you thought you should have
protected him and now you're just
hell-bent on protecting everybody else
to the point that you're neglecting
yourself and probably suffocating them a
bit is that fair
fair
very fair
here's what really sucks is it's been
two years
and i don't think you've grieved yet
i think you've been hurting like bloody
hell for two years but i don't think
you've started grieving yet
and this is gonna be the hardest thing i
say on this whole call and i'll get
choked up here if i'm not careful
there's gonna have to come a moment when
you forgive louise
and there's gonna have to come a moment
when you tell louise said i love you and
there's gonna have to come a moment when
you open your hands and let luis go
and no mama ever
ever ever should have to let her baby go
and that doesn't have to be the day that
i didn't have to be tomorrow that i have
to be in three four weeks
but until you let louise go not that
you're not gonna remember them not that
you're still gonna have photos up of
course you're gonna have those things of
course you're gonna develop a
scholarship for him and you're gonna
give a talk to a local school about kids
and mental health you're gonna do those
things his memory will stay alive
but you're still sitting in the floor of
your home hugging his body
right
yeah
just like haven't been able to separate
yeah that
of like yes his memory still lives on
but i can't let him go that's right
and this is one of those things man that
you i know listeners probably this time
who listened to this conversation rolled
her eyes at this point but at some point
you write him his long his letter his
goodbye letter
have you done that yet no
no
and as a mental health professional you
know that's what you got to do
but you got to tell him goodbye
and whether you go out to his grave and
you read it to him
or you ride it and you take it out to
the lake and
let it out into the water whatever that
looks like for you
but you're gonna have to tell him you're
sorry you're gonna tell me forgive him
you're gonna tell me you'll love him
you have to tell them that you're gonna
do your best you you can to make meaning
of what happened and
live
and that you're gonna laugh again and
you're gonna smile again you're gonna
find joy again whatever that looks like
and that's going to be years and years
and years
so here's a couple of things that you
said that i want to make sure i touch on
okay and i know right now you may not
even be hearing me anymore
um
but i want you to go back and have this
to listen to and also the people
listening okay
it's really important that you don't
hide your grief from your other kids
because they feel it at different levels
too
and they need to know that mom that
they're not crazy and that mom's not a
robot
and so if they come in
and you are it's right up there on the
surface
or his birthday comes up
or christmas happens and there's not a
stocking on the wall with his name on it
and you just have one of those or
one of those moments you just
come out of the bathroom and it hits you
um
and one of your kids is with you and
you're on the floor
curled up weeping let your kids come hug
you don't hide that from them
and if they say what's wrong mama what's
wrong say i really really miss
louise
i miss him today
say the words out loud grief demands a
witness
and you're not protecting them by hiding
from them okay
okay
here's the second thing
i don't know what you think you're
supposed to be feeling right now but
grief is is
this from
kessler's work man grief is as unique as
your fingerprint
there's no right way to do this you do
have to keep
paying your bills and you do have to
keep eating and you do have to keep
moving your body and you do have mouths
to feed in your home
but you're allowed to hurt
and you're allowed to feel like you are
underwater
and you're allowed to wake up on
saturdays and say i just can't do it
today
that's when the hard work you have to do
is to make sure you've got somebody you
can call they'll come pick up your kids
and go play
is that fair
can't do this by yourself
the journey moving forward is having a
light having a purpose having a reason
you may have to take some time for
healing and then go back to work
maybe you have to switch to the
classroom work in the lunchroom i don't
care be an administrator i don't know
whatever what i know that every state's
different with how they are able to move
people around but it may just be a
season where you need some healing
and you'll come back strong
or you say dude i'm out of this i'm
going to start a lawn business i don't i
don't know right
but
i threw a lot of stuff at you tell me
where your heart's at right now
obviously you don't feel better and i
knew that in this phone call and
obviously you don't have all your
answers but
tell me what's going on in your heart
and mine
i'm sorry um
i just
um that's i think a big part of why i
reached out to you as well is because
i'm really struggling with
leaving the profession
in general
um as part of my healing and
taking a different route
to
just
heal
in a different way and to help people
in a different way not the mental health
aspect but a different way and um
so this is good to hear for my
own
journey um here's who you are luisa you
are someone who helps other people
yeah and if i got fired tomorrow if i
lost my job if nobody listened to this
podcast ever again
and i started working at burger king
i would be somebody who wanted to help
people there
yeah and if i went to be an elementary
school teacher again like i did one year
one chaotic crazy year
i would want to help those kids and if i
went back to teaching high school or
being a college professor i'd be a
helper that's just what i do and that's
who you are
um i don't think you're done forever
it sounds like a
that as close as your profession is
to what the hurt that you have
um it seems like a break makes sense
and it might be two months that might be
three months that might not be forever
um
it may look totally different but you're
gonna be someone who loves and serves
and helps other people
i can't think of a better thing for you
to do than to get with a group of moms
who've had your experience there in
denver colorado
and
the idea of that on the outside sounds
like hell and i know that the last thing
you'd want to do is go to have this
conversation with 15 other people
grief demands a witness
somebody has to hear your story which
means you have to speak your story out
loud
and other moms who have been down the
road a little bit further than you and a
lot of other moms who are just just are
still raw
um that's what healing looks like and
i'll even throw dads in there parents in
there
you understand this intellectually and
your body is overwhelmed
you experience something that the human
body is not designed to experience
no parent should find their child who's
passed away
no parent should hug their child who's
passed away no parent should bury a
child
it's not the way this thing works
and so the healing out of this is going
to be unique and it's going to take
other people and it's going to take a
mission of some sort
before i before i let you go will you
say i'm worth being well i want to hear
you say those words
i'm worth being well
and i'm worth being loved
and i'm worth being loved and i'm worth
laughing one day
and i'm worth laughing one day
and i love my baby boy
and they love my baby boy
and it wasn't my fault
and it wasn't my fault
you're a brave brave sister
and thank you so much for sharing your
journey with us
please please please please please make
a call today
make one call to a group and say today's
the day
circle your kids up and say hey mom's
been really struggling with
with brothers death even though it was
two years ago i'm still struggling big
time and i will be for a long time
someone's y'all don't know
today's the day thank you so much
so sorry that your son passed away i'm
so sorry that
you're hurting like you have been your
family's hurting